hello welcome to another exciting
episode of the movieclips instant
trailer V show I'm Jimmy I'm Ryan and
today we were reviewing Seth
MacFarlane's new feature film a million
ways to die in the west um which
seemingly after the success of Ted Seth
MacFarlane can do and anything he wants
and get anyone he wants to be in it so
what does he do he makes a Western he
makes a Western gets a whole bunch of
celebrity and I'll be honest it's a it's
a cool-looking trailer now it's red band
as soon as they started doing this you
kind of know where this is going yeah
but they really play up the death expect
in this like I thought that was just
kind of a title but there's a lot of
people dying in this trailer like the
topic of the trailer is death yeah um so
there Casey didn't know he did Ted and
Family Guy and the convention family guy
yeah actually we should note that this
is the first time than Seth MacFarlane
is kind of starring in anything right as
a person now already a voice as you as
you just touched on the premise of this
movie I guess is really just gonna be
surviving yeah so it sounds like said
we're all and watched a lot of westerns
was like people die a lot means yeah and
he was like let's make a movie about
that it's continuing that's not Giovanni
Ribisi but we already saw yeah we cease
completely this love affair with
Giovanni Ribisi apparently ya know if
you if you don't remember was the really
creepy guy from tip and obsessed with
Tiffany yeah oh yeah
so there's liam neeson uh which is
insane the doctor I love that yeah it's
weird again splintered dog um so Liam
nice mirror to saw that charlize theron
right the caliber of cast in this movie
is is unreal right so there's I mean it
looks like like family guy and Ted it's
very visually gag yeah Anton um but I
thought you know family guy felt like it
was kind of petering out in terms of
comedy and things Ted was really really
really funny like that kind of humor
translated well to a live-action another
sound familiar and so I'm really excited
for this movie I think it's good night
and I'm really excited Liam Neeson is
hysterical I mean this Sarah Silverman
Sarah Silverman's in it strong I'm also
freed that mean is a full casting this
is nice and all she acts are just really
great the anachronistic kind of way that
he's approaching this in terms of like
no one really talks like they're in the
West they talk about contemporary it's
great um and all the gags are kind of
contemporary no Patrick Harris and a
mantis I free yeah live and the I'm glad
that they did a red band trailer because
they really i don't think a green right
out it could really get a gross gags are
so good like all the dialogue is amazing
yeah i do think it's really interesting
though that he's playing the lead
character out because after he got rid
of all the animated elements like Ted he
really there was nothing for him to do
and his voice is so specific to his
writing and it's it you can't hide him
ya can't hide behind it and it's not
like the like he's not the only
filmmaker to utilize that Guillermo del
Toro put him in hell boy too I mean this
this movie seems like it's gonna be just
a little bit not that's another listen
not that Ted didn't have a story but I
think that this this film is gonna be
the four-letter Gag Gag Gag Gag and more
he says Mila Kunis
so he's there still pop culture
references I all over the place yeah
it's gonna have to find more creative
ways to do it exactly so there's going
to be a great hallucinogenic sequence
the fact the real surprise obviously
there's he loves musicals yaps as good
as the musical sequence um the fact that
he got Liam Neeson is really the biggest
surprise for me yeah charlize theron is
kind of known to be like a good job Mike
really fun exactly Liam Neeson nothing's
not but Liam Neeson also i saw an
interview with him i forget which talk
show is on where he said that his when
his son had like people sleeping over he
left the taken voicemail message on
there unlike their friends voicemail
boxes and stuff like that so he's got
he's got a sense of humor but he needs a
good time charlie yeah he's a good time
Charlie I'll I think this might be my
favorite
so yeah I mean honestly I can I really
have nothing to say it looks like a
rip-roaring time I love anything else
I'm so excited are you excited about it
let us know in the comments section
below Jimmy and I have nothing else to
say really it speaks for itself no it
does it's really funny i'm excited about
the movie until next time I'm Ryan I'm
Jimmy thanks for watching
touch